during the american revolution everyone
became
a little bit of a philosopher walking
down the street in boston
past coffee houses and taverns
you might hear ordinary people debating
equality and
natural rights before it was even a
political revolution
the american revolution was a revolution
of ideas
you see these ideas all over the
literature of the time period
perhaps most famously in thomas
jefferson's language in the declaration
that all men are created equal endowed
with certain
unalienable rights the idea that
everyone has
the natural right to life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
you would see it in the most famous
slogan of the revolution
no taxation without representation the
idea that
the people should have a say in the laws
that affect them
the revolution even went so far as to
criticize the idea of
monarchy which pamphlet thomas paine
called absurd
these ideas criticized long-standing
social norms
about who deserved to rule versus who
deserved
to be ruled it's likely that most of the
founders thought these ideas
primarily applied to the political
struggle between the colonies and great
britain
but it wasn't just elite white men who
considered these
radical notions and thought about how to
apply them to their own lives
these revolutionary ideals increased the
awareness of inequalities in society
more broadly
and caused some people to call for
changes in voting rights
in the institution of slavery and the
status of women
one major change that the revolutionary
ideals
caused was an expansion of political
democracy
in state governments so after the
revolution
all the states wrote new constitutions
and every one of them instituted a
representative government
through an elected legislature and
almost all of them
also reduced the property requirements
for voting
and office holding which previously had
limited the franchise
to wealthier white men after the
revolution
a majority of white men had the right to
vote and voting rights
would continue to expand until all white
men
had the right to vote by the 1830s
in fact some state constitutions like
new jersey's
didn't specify who could vote so long as
they met
the new lower property requirements so
between the revolution
and 1807 when they changed the law
property owning women
and free people of color could vote
another social change that was brought
on by these revolutionary ideals
was the emergence of the abolition
movement
to end the practice of slavery so almost
all of the founders were slave owners
and they didn't seem to notice any
contradiction between the idea that all
men are created equal
and keeping africans in perpetual
bondage but
that did not mean that others missed the
connection during the revolution itself
many enslaved people escaped filed
petitions for freedom
or they joined the military to gain
freedom
on the side of the americans but more
frequently on the side of the british
who offered freedom in exchange for
serving in the army
after the revolution northern states
either abolished slavery
or they began a process of gradual
emancipation
so saying that enslaved people who were
children
might remain in slavery until they were
in their mid to late
20s and then would be free and their
children would be free
so that over the course of the late
1800s
and early 1900s in most northern states
slavery was either entirely
eliminated or phased out to the point
that there was a very small enslaved
population
southern states did not abolish slavery
in response to the revolution
and this would continue to expand
sectional tensions between the north and
the south until the civil war
the last change in social values that i
want to discuss
relates to women's role in the war women
played
a pretty crucial role in supporting the
independence movement
and they also drew on the rhetoric of
revolutionary ideas
to support their claims for an
improvement in status
abigail adams who was the wife of john
adams
wrote to him while he was in
philadelphia working on the draft of the
declaration of independence
with thomas jefferson and others she
wrote
in the new code of laws which i suppose
it will be necessary for you to make
a desire you would remember the ladies
and be more generous
and favorable to them than your
ancestors if particular care and
attention
is not paid to the ladies we are
determined to foment a rebellion
and will not hold ourselves bound by any
laws in which we have no voice or
representation
in general the revolution didn't result
in a huge
change of status for white women and
none at all for enslaved women but one
idea did emerge
that would foment social change farther
down the line
and that was the idea of republican
motherhood
so republican motherhood was the notion
that
for this new democratic american nation
to work
the country was going to need virtuous
citizens
and who taught men how to be virtuous
citizens
they're mothers so thinkers of the time
period
particularly a philadelphia physician
and
signer of the declaration of
independence named benjamin rush
argued that women should receive more
robust
education in order to better educate
their sons
so instead of only learning household
skills or etiquette
women should learn philosophy and
mathematics
now while this concept was mainly in the
service
of improving the education and virtue
of men it did result in the expansion of
women's education
and the founding of new schools and
colleges for girls
and many of the girls who attended those
schools would go on to be
major reformers and activists in the
women's rights
and abolitionist movements in the 19th
century
i want to finish by just briefly taking
a look at
john adams response to his wife's letter
encouraging him to remember the ladies
which is not nearly as famous
as her letter but i think still tells us
a lot about
the ideas of the time period he said as
to your extraordinary code of laws
i cannot but laugh we have been told
that our struggle has loosened the bans
of government everywhere
that children and apprentices were
disobedient that schools and colleges
were grown turbulent
that indians slighted their guardians
and negroes grew
insolent to their masters but your
letter was the first
intimation that another tribe more
numerous and powerful than all the rest
were grown discontented
and there at the end he's referring to
women you can tell that
john kind of takes this as a joke he
can't imagine
that the ideas that he and the other
founders used so persuasively
in the american revolution would lead
women and african americans
and working class people like
apprentices
to apply those same notions to
themselves but perhaps the joke was on
john adams
after all because that is exactly what
they did